next we got a rip my drip sorry Derek
it's okay buddy first I'm sorry my
friends racist keep going yeah I'm sorry
my friend ha ha ha I'm sorry my friends
races and blames it keys from New
Orleans dude I'm from New Orleans man
I'm sorry my friend thing said the fifth
grade is high school okay
I'm here bro this is Sebastian from
Ontario Sebastian whoo [ __ ] what is this
what is this was this home depot
psychopath bro he looks like Kant
applause okay this guy who looks like he
sure says I don't exist back with Santa
Claus on it for the listeners bro he
looks like one of the sons of the Wet
Bandits okay dude he looks so mean Derek
what do you think about he looks exactly
like the bad guy from The Smurfs oh my
god a hair and everything that's a good
call this guy's one bad break off from
just [ __ ] up that entire wherever he
works it works in a shop it's called a
shop duties were men work at that's not
a shop dude that's the back of [ __ ]
Costco it's not a shop look at that
giant [ __ ] fan look at all the [ __ ]
they're selling you didn't get couches
at a shop look back there he hasn't
closed who was close to her Costco do
those guys were you know who we're them
guys who were serious about the [ __ ]
that's who wears them cuz they don't
want calluses of their hands dudes a
green boat next to him I don't know what
that is yeah you do what this might be
area 51
Oh could be two guys it's he's an alien
he looks like uh he looks a little bit
like John Malkovich's angry son dude
yeah like he looks like Of Mice and
Meineke like he works at a [ __ ] brake
shop he looks [ __ ] piss
he just looks so dark yeah this is all
mining equipment he's at a mining it
place look he looks at miner no wait
really
yeah hell yeah dude shoutout to miners
dish out the miners shove to the
Nautilus a shout-out to my sauce no
shout to my a shout-out to the [ __ ] who
escaped the basement and pulp fiction
and now found a job Wow
I don't see him like that at all esteem
as a young man who you're not young
they'll shut up to him for sponsoring
this guy what is this thing is called
Punk mile no this is just a rip my drip
close forgot his job how about his
[ __ ] Columbine blower half okay focus
on his style I will say this great
gloves
dark clothing a picture of one trench
coat away from joining the band my man
you definitely should not be allowed
inside of Burlington Coat Factory okay
you're going from there I can tell so I
think yeah I would brighten up the the
clothing cavity total palette there's
more than plastic what do you think he
could do I mean maybe black is a good
call he's a minor
he gets dirty real easily sure that's
good maybe he has to wear black on me
but he wants to let everyone know that
he loves Christmas yeah or he does it
yeah well putting up the code on your
style in your heart bro there's more
than black yeah it's funny cuz he
dresses in black but looks like he
doesn't like it
that's kind of an interesting look hey
man he's pissed yes we're bloody god
bless you brother and we'll be thinking
about you man yeah we well good luck
dude Wow thanks for closing that JPEG
then you guys feel better when he closed
down this guy wind up on first 48
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]